I came across this phrase cattle Epps's
right a sense of certainty or truth from
which nothing can dislodge us a mystical
experience a moment of visionary
understanding as Isaiah Berlin said to
understand is to perceive patterns when
the dots connect and the new Gestalt
appears and you see the big picture a
truth from which nothing can dislodge us
and we're all hungry for this kind of
certainty we're all looking for this
kind of existential reassurance or story
that feels real and that imbues our
lives with meaning and signification we
are storytelling animals wire rich
mythologist narratives that envelop us
in truth the question remains right
in a world in which our rational
faculties constantly poke holes in our
most treasured narratives
we've instead moved into a realm where
existential doubts and existential grief
is the new normal nothing is certain
except death and taxes as they say and
you know what this has done this has
dislodged us from our comfort zone we
are off the reservation we know not
where we're going which direction we are
flowing you know it feels like that
scene in Willy Wonka when they go
through the funhouse tunnel depression
and anxiety are epidemic levels
tribalism and nationalism is on the rise
our hunger for meaning is making us foam
at the mouth I'm not proud of a lot of
the actions we've taken but I understand
where that hunger comes from what are we
to do inspired ones tell us well let's
upgrade human consciousness right when
astronauts go into orbit they experience
what's known as the overview effect as
they oversee the planet as a whole an
integrated super organism with billions
of minds consciousness is life there it
is right
a marble floating in the cosmos so much
more than a mote of dust my friends
there is the miracle and we are a part
of the miracle and that transformation
in consciousness that shift in
perspective seems to heal us of our
fractures how do we expand the
distribution channels for an overview
effect experience do we give everybody
psychedelics do we create spas for the
mind where people can go and partake in
visionary mystical experiences with the
mysterium tremendum in order to come out
on the other side more empathetic more
compassionate filled with a sense of
purpose and filled with a sense of
service because that's what happens when
you glimpse great
truth right the truth of the poets the
truth of the mystics the truth of
visionary understanding that we exist
right that we may contribute a verse if
we may contribute first and this is what
we must do we must alkalis a
transformative shift in perception and
self perception in the way we perceive
the other to realize that the other is
ourselves to God and Marvel in visionary
understanding to neuro ourselves to
experience bliss mock crucifixions to
submit so that we might die so that we
might be reborn right apotheosis for all
this is what
[Music]
Nirvana points the way we must
synthesize transformations and
consciousness that seed transformations
of culture powered by that desire for
higher truth to God just to see and I
was looking at me
[Music]